صحيح اننا على بعد ايام قليله فقط على
انطلاق هذا المونديال لكن اود ان اعود بك
سيد حسن وبالذات بذاكرتك الى البدايات
اتحدث عن سنه 2000 2010 ما الذي جعل
باعتقادك الملف القطري يفوز امام دول
كبيره
على اساس انه يكون في جماعه عربي ودعم
عربي للملف من نعزز فكره ان هذه البطوله
العربيه في الدرجه الاساسي الاساسيه فلما
كنا نتكلم كنا نتكلم
بصوت في الوطن العربي وبفكره ان الوطن
العربي الوطن العربي ان يكون متواجد همم
في همم استضافه الاحداث الكبرى العالميه
الكبرى ان يتقدم قرابه نصف مليون من
المتطوع من المختلف اصدقاء العالم
للعمل مجانا في هذا المونديال ما الذي
يمثله من اول يوم قدمنا في الملف المؤمنين
قوه كره القدم كاس العالم بشكل عام على
نهايه استطيع ان يتقرب ما بين الشعوب انا
في وجهه نظري نجاح اي بطوله احد العناصر
الاساسيه والرئيسيه هم المتطوعين استمرار
هذه الحمله هذا التشكيك الى حد خلاص احنا
على بعض ايام المونديال ماذا تراه فيه احد
يعمل اسواق في هذا الموضوع انه عندهم فكره
موجوده
غرسه في العالم الغربي على مرحله اجيال
قصور سواكن نشوفه في طريقه تجسيد العرب في
الافلام في الكتب في الروايات ايا كانت
بشكل عام كانت دائما فكره ان ناس غير
متحضرين او ناس
الايجابيه الوحيده الموجود من الحديث ومن
المعلومات لا في في كانت اهداف سياسيه
داخليه
التعلق في بعض الامور الاقتصاديه موجوده
عندهم
اكثر من مشجعين الذين همم المنطقه
كاس العالم بشكل بشكل عام هي في تقارب
الشعوب وتقارب الجماهير بينهم وبين بعض
هذه هذه يمكن بالنسبه يعني سر النجاح
البطوله والسر تغيير الفكره النبطيه كلنا
امل وكلنا ثقه ان اللي يزور قطر وتعامل مع
جميع اللي موجودين هنا راح يتحولون
السفراء للسفراء الوطن العربي لما يرجعون
الى بلادنا نتحدث قليل الان عن الانسان
مليار دولار على بطوله كاس العالم
البريطانيه يعني نحن نتحدث عن قربه 20 مره
اضعاف روسيا 2018 وصف الرقم غير دقيقه ال
200 مليار هو رقم
يجمع جميع مشاريع البنيه التحتيه لدوله
قطر مشاريع هذه مشاريع كواتب اولا رؤيه
قطع 2030 وايضا
رؤيه البنيه التحتيه او او بنيه تحتيه
وخطط تطوير البلد بشكل عام تامين
المونديال من كل النواحي في هذا الموضوع
ما هي تحضيراتكم اجمالي حساب الخبرات من
البطولات العالميه هذا هذا احد الاشياء
اللي عملنا عليها طبعا وضع الخطه من 2013
الى الان همم الاستعانه والخبرات العالميه
طبعا موجوده الان اعتقد على حسب الطناعي
همم
افضل الانظمه اللي موجود في العالم لاننا
نصنع التاريخ بمونديال قطر 2022 الذي يمكن
ان تقدمه فعلا
من خلال هذا الموسم في البطوله هذه الاساس
لتغيير الفكره النبطيه ان لم تكن في
الاعلام وتكون البشر وتكون هناك الشخص
للشعب للشعوب الجماهير يتمثل الشعوب
الشعوب الكوادر اللي موجوده هذه خبراته
موجوده باذن الله رح يتم في الوطن العربي
راح تساهم وتساعد وتعزز من همم تدوير همم
الكوادر والشباب العربي اللي موجود وخلق
فرس اخرى موجوده
[موسيقى]